[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back here on overtime and here's
the first question to you Suze Orman how
do you feel about the buy gold and end
the Fed crowd crowd
I think of Ron Paul when I hear that
he's a whack job who tells when he
speaks you know he's telling the joke
pandering I gotta love him just for that
but I agree on this and that's what I'm
talking about here last time he ran I
said the same thing it's it's just a
nutty idea and it's not gonna happen
it's it's throwing our lot it took the
whims of the mining industry and
everything else so that isn't the
problem
his suggestion to go back to that is not
the solution so he's just talking about
the topic so many people who are big Ron
Paul fans that's the younger people and
I understand why they love him on the
issues that I love him on why is a guy
who in my view was so out ahead on these
issues
what is his what is in his brain that he
can't get past the gold thing I have to
tell I'm not sure and I didn't know what
it was even four years ago he was really
on to this as well I don't know why and
he was dead wrong when he said four
years ago in the collapse that we'd have
hyperinflation so Ron Paul lovers I just
just know that but he does say I wish he
actually was more popular than he was I
do do it a few he just needs a little
tweaking and he'd probably be the best
for that I think it's gonna take a
little more than a little tweaking
though I mean I mean he has know it is
great that he says exactly what he means
and that is incredibly refreshing it's
just that it's just a little crazy
sometimes also health care I'm not good
on that but you know without the crazies
Ralph Nader right I mean we were on a
dog hunt
I mean he's not in the Republican Party
or the Democratic Party right you're
right okay did President Obama
inappropriately politicize the National
Prayer Breakfast by suggesting Jesus
would support
taxing the rich he said for unto whom
much is given much shall be required and
went on to say and I believe in God's
command to love thy neighbor as thyself
boy is always controversial that seems
more plausible than have an account in
the Caymans
you know the things that they can I mean
one of the republican congressmen walked
out on the prayer breakfast this is just
you know it's like somebody yelled you
lied then they stuck a finger in his
face now I'll walk out on the prayer
breakfast they're just upping the ante
and how they can disrespect the black
president in my view president is they
never did any of that to any other
president and I and I saw the probe
represent President Obama did not say
Jesus says tax the rich that never came
out of his but what what President Obama
was talking about was he was talking
about in the book of Proverbs proverbs
is how basically we're gonna be known
about how we treat the least of us and
he's absolutely right the thing that is
the thing that it that makes this
country so great is the fact that we as
a country it's the idea of what America
is America is the purest meritocracy
that the world has and all we're simply
saying is is that if we have massive
disparities between Americans we're not
living up to our best ideals
we're not the country that I know we can
be so that's simply the point that was
trying to make this is not about class
warfare anything on science what class
warfare is is the fact that we have so
many people is the fact that we have 46
million people living in poverty and the
fact that the top 1% now controls 25
percent of all the income in this
country that's class warfare you have
you have a silver-tongued it again my
speech making friend and also you know I
mean I of course I'm not a believer in
gods but you know I did read Jesus's
book and I loved his philosophy and you
know if there's one thing that he seems
to have a real bug up his ass about it's
be nice to poor people and I don't like
rich people he doesn't like rich people
and he loves poor people he said he
didn't write the book right correct
neither it was the hippie buddy need to
did anybody who ever lived with no and I
think people think that the Gospels are
written by his disciples that's not who
Mark Matthew Mark Luke and John you look
at you
well people argue with that they'd they
insist that Matthew Mark Luke and John
were his disciples they were not they
lived 40 to 70 years after he died so
but anyway this is what this is what his
PR people and what they put out was in
it's a constant team it's a constant
drumbeat be nice to poor people rich
people cannot get into heaven it's like
going through the eye of the needle that
whole thing so you know how this party
is able to align their hyper Christian
activity and and okay
so he's gonna do he's gonna hear you're
gonna know and this goes back to your
earlier point like why
why why is it that these people making
50,000 bucks like Republicans okay
because they don't think that what the
Democrats do not they don't mean well
but what they do doesn't work that the
whole income transfer thing doesn't make
up for the fact that I need to get a
good job and to get a good job I need a
good education and yes it has to be a
meritocracy but there's got to be a
system it I basically know that if the
employers are getting crushed that's not
helping me out that's that's not a good
end game I dig you're right on the money
they do not think they I think is
exactly what they think the Democrats
have good intentions but they think it
doesn't work and the reason of course it
doesn't work is because it's blocked by
Republican a lot of the reason why Obama
has not been able to move the economy
more forward different rules which was
the filibuster it wasn't there wasn't
that what I was called the silent coup
in America used to be you had a you only
need a little majority a you direct
majority and this used to need 51 votes
now you need 60 so you can't guess what
I think releases especially since he's
got like 10 or 20 people in his own
party who are really Republic its closet
so here's what I think is probably I
think he's a very smart guy I just think
he's just not a loser
I think he doesn't like Clinton he's not
a schmoozer he was a charmer okay so
Republicans could hate him but they
could love him at the same time and he
right I was watching yeah Obama after
the State of Union walk out in the way
the difference in the way he treated
Republicans and Democrats was so stark
in my mind and if it was Clinton and I
was there for this you know you could
step in the back night before if you saw
you peeping like right man what's going
on how about that Super Bowl you know
right won't you come over you rat
exactly and you know that's here can can
argue with that all that the full Monica
[Laughter]
Real Time with Bill Maher ask bill and
his guests to a questions right after
the show at hbo.com